I've been with my wife for about 10
years I've been married for seven years
we met because we lived in the same dorm
freshman year of college I've been
married for about two and a half years
we were set up by my best friend who
married us I've never once she's a
dating app you mind
Tyla dating apps didn't exist when I was
single
OkCupid was a thing when I was in
college but it was kind of like there's
a certain type of person who online
dated at that point I don't even know if
I've ever been on a date tinder scares
me it feels a little shallow and
judgmental so I'm putting on tinder for
the first time which way do I swipe for
the first person on my tinder is saucy
as hell
definitely not Griffin oh oh it's a
match it's a match oh boy okay wait
joy did one message this is you with
your mother this is actually just like a
video game and it's really fun oh gosh I
just got a match what the hell does that
mean super like Ryan no no isn't weird
to send like multiple messages to a
stranger like I just messaged three
times in a row
my second photo is a photo taken to my
wedding day he's looking for fun
friendship and possibly a green card
like that's funny I don't know which one
this guy is they're like eight people in
this profile if I was on tinder my bio
would be just like I just a string of
eggplant emoji just straightforward I
think that a lot of these men on here
are confused as to what is attractive to
women
tinder was really fun but I feel like as
soon as I get a response back then it's
gonna be like really daunting and scary
I feel weird gamifying something that
could be real I would think I would
definitely use tinder I actually think
it'd be something fun for my husband
that I had to play together as like a
judging people sort of thing being right
[ __ ] rules
it does feel like there's a bunch of
wonderful people here can I just have a
tender for friends I want to meet that
wanna hang out I'll bring my wife